your second one is on the way and we got
you a little gift a little yeah you do
oh my gosh would you get me you're in
the family now so of course I'm just
gonna relax how is it the second time or
how are things different this baby is
definitely showing me his personality is
bopping around and jumping and doing a
whole bunch of stuff your daughter has
been talking to her brother yeah she
does and it's just so cute she rubs my
belly and kisses my belly so cute
your new Netflix show soundtrack drops
today right now you can go and stream it
it tells love stories through music
did you and Jenna Dewan plan your
pregnancies because you both are
pregnant at the same time something in
the air she called me like a month after
I announced it and she was like oh my
gosh girl I'm pregnant too all we do is
talk about how bloated we feel I'm gonna
take you back for a second my first
starring role in a movie so I was just
I'm excited finally now I'm on the red
carpet you do you do you remember that
do you remember this moment love don't
cost a thing had just come out that's a
really it's really refreshing seeing
that it was all hitting me at once and
it was you know the dream was coming
alive who wouldn't know and the battle
team movie would become like a classic
that people still talk about people
still watch
[Music]